we must also d glamorized the extremists  cause especially ISIL this is a group  that throws people of buildings that  burns them alive and as Channel 4's  documentary last week showed its men  rape underage girls and stone innocent  women to death this isn't a pioneering  movement it is a vicious brutal and  fundamentally abhor a'n't existence and  here's my message to any young person  here in Britain thinking of going out  there you won't be some valued member of  a movement you are cannon fodder for  them they will use you if you're a boy  they will brainwash you strap bombs to  your body and blow you up if you are a  girl they will enslave and abuse you  that is the sick and brutal reality of  ISIL so when we bring forward our  counter extremism strategy in the autumn  here are the things we'll be looking at  using people who really understand the  true nature of what life is like under  ISIL to communicate to young and  vulnerable people the brutal reality of  this ideology